good afternoon
class of 2016 masters Dean's colleagues
and friends my name is Mara shell gentry
and I'm a senior associate dean of Yale
College and Dean of Student Affairs on
behalf of all my colleagues in yale
college i'd like to welcome utl and to
this orientation keynote address at this
time I ask that you disable all cell
phones and electronic devices and now it
gives me great pleasure to introduce
Mary Miller the Dean of Yale College and
sterling professor of history of art
before taking on the deanship Dean
Miller served as master of sabra college
from 1999
until she became Dean of Yale College in
2008 dean miller also has served as the
chair of the history of art department
Dean Miller received her degrees from
Princeton and Yale University's and for
30 years she's been a leader in in the
study of the ancient world receiving
both the guggenheim fellowship and
membership into the american academy of
arts and sciences as you now know Dean
Miller is an internationally recognized
expert on Mayan art and architecture
having published six major books and is
under contract for her seventh book with
the university of texas press dean
miller recently presented the 59th aw
mellon lectures in the fine arts series
at the National Gallery of Art in
Washington DC Dean Miller also will
deliver the Slade lectures at Cambridge
University in 2014 and 2015 the two
lecture series are considered the most
prestigious in the field of art history
Dean Miller will now come to introduce
our keynote speaker
well it's so nice to see you all again
and so soon I saw so many of you this
afternoon at the academic fair when I
have to say most of you were in shorts
and t-shirts so let me now suggest that
you if you have a say a jacket on that
you can shed I want to encourage you to
remove it because it is hot in here
and I just want to draw your attention
to the upper story the clear story of
windows here which open only twice a
year once for the freshman address and
if necessary for baccalaureate and for
no other occasions not even this one so
that's why we're going to be
particularly hot in here this afternoon
but not so bad and particularly now that
men have taken off their suit jackets if
they felt like it I hope everyone's a
little more comfortable it's my pleasure
this afternoon to introduce to you
Charles Balin the a Bartlett Giamatti
professor of astronomy and physics at
Yale University and I suspect that
barring that title means something in
particular to Charles Balin who was here
during the presidency of Bart Giamatti
when he graduated from Yale in 1981 he
earned his PhD from Harvard six years
later and joined the y el faculty
shortly thereafter and he's now been at
Yale teaching astronomy and physics 22
years just this year for years he taught
gateways different kinds of gateway
courses to astronomy to Yale
undergraduates particularly courses that
excited non-scientists right alongside
students with scientific aspirations
using his own exciting research in black
holes as the springboard but his desire
for new frontiers led him out of his
what I would say the bread and butter
courses of his department when in 2008
he in an associate professor of
Religious Studies taught for the first
time of course they would teach at least
one time after that religion and the
Bing Big Bang the idea that an
astronomer and a religious studies
professor would come together to
asked the critical questions about where
we come from and where we are going for
his incredible contribution in the
classroom professor Balin has earned the
Dillon Hickson prize the highest
teaching award in the natural sciences
so I don't think I really need to tell
you to listen up but I will anyhow
because I think we're in for a
stimulating afternoon professor Balin
Thank You Dean Miller Thank You Dean
gentry and thanks to all of you for the
opportunity to talk to you on what is
after all the very last day of your life
that you haven't yet taken a Yale class
so it turns out that the universe is
made of bubbles this discovery was made
when I was a student someone carried out
a large survey of the positions of
galaxies throughout the universe and
showed that the galaxies are not
distributed randomly rather there are
great voids containing almost no
galaxies surrounded by giant walls
filled with galaxies just like a big tub
full of soap bubbles with the voids in
the middle of the individual bubbles and
the walls at the sides the media made a
big deal out of this lots of headlines
about how God is forever blowing bubbles
things of this nature in terms of its
overall structure the university is
perhaps not so different from the
universe and in fact people often refer
to the so-called Yale bubble what they
mean by this is that there are walls
between the inside of Yale and
everything else on the outside some of
these walls are physical the residential
colleges are after all gated communities
and only those with certain privileges
can enter human nature is such that
people often very much desire to be led
into places that are restricted
regardless of what's actually inside but
even more so if the inside is perceived
to be a good thing in the case of Yale
as you're all acutely aware it's quite
hard to be allowed in and as you're
perhaps beginning to discover once
you're in it's a pretty nice place to be
as an aside I should tell you most
faculty members do not in fact have key
cards that open the residential colleges
this causes some bitterness since the
faculty are under the mistaken
impression that they are important
people around here so don't be alarmed
if you see a scruffy middle-aged person
hanging around the gates of your
residential college don't stand for the
cops
it's probably just a slightly irritated
faculty member waiting for some more
privileged individual to let him or her
into the true inner sanctums of Yale
which are of course the place is
occupied by the undergraduates but the
Yale bubble doesn't refer only to
physical barriers these gates are
manifestations of much deeper
psychological boundaries there's a huge
amount going on at Yale that is
available only to those inside we have
classes entertainment's meals debates
and arguments of all kinds distinguished
visitors high-level networking
opportunities formal and informal social
events and every sort of extracurricular
activity both licit and illicit
occasionally you might even get a chance
to rest and think it makes the rest of
the world seem dull and faded there's
just so much to do here and you get to
do it with such interesting people
people just like you except maybe a
little bit smarter and better looking
gotta keep at it faster and faster you
might miss something and of course you
will miss things but that is as the
computer scientists like to say a
feature not a bug the whole point is
that there's something for everyone here
and then some a whole universe of
activities far greater than any one
person can take in I use the word
universe here not as a metaphor but in
its technical sense technically the
universe comprises everything that can
ever possibly be seen or can possibly
exert any other sort of influence on any
observer situated within it and it's
tempting to think that the university
has the same features that activities
taking place outside the walls of the
Yale bubble really don't influence what
goes on inside but this is a mistake
just because Yale has too much going on
for one person to absorb doesn't mean
that the outside world has ceased to
exist sometimes the influence is all too
obvious eleven years ago this fall the
twin towers fell during one of the most
popular time slots for Yale classes
students and faculty emerge from their
classrooms to find the whole place in an
uproar it was like coming out of a dark
theater into a bright afternoon sunlight
I remember it was hard to figure out how
to respond did one just keep giving
classes stop all regular activities it
was certainly hard to focus on formal
teaching and learning for a little while
or was it our obligation to keep the
bubble intact to keep doing our thing in
the face of adversity in danger
different people responded differently
and while I certainly hope that no such
dramatic event Mars your stay here at
Yale it's worth keeping in mind that our
internal activities might be disrupted
at any moment by events from the outside
and it can be sometimes awkward to deal
with the outside world who you go to
Yale you must be so smart pollies you
know sometimes one even goes so far as
to deny being a Yalie at all have you
guys done this yet oh I'm at a small
College in Connecticut you've probably
never heard of it it's called Ezra
Stiles
we all do it eventually it just gets too
embarrassing to acknowledge the
privilege it is to be here to those who
for whatever reason don't have the
opportunity and maybe we should be a bit
embarrassed there are of course many
others who deserve to be here as much as
we do but whether deserved or not this
embarrassment makes it easier to hang
out with people who share the privilege
of being here it's nice not to
constantly have to justify one's
existence and it's nice not to have to
explain all the in group vocabulary that
we use so freely with each other but
there's a real danger created by
succumbing to this temptation and
staying inside the bubble namely it
gives the things we do here and
unnatural heightened importance and that
in turn makes us attribute dire
existential consequences to things that
are really not in a cosmic sense big
deals that test that try out that
insulting remark maybe it doesn't matter
quite as much as you think so now let me
give you all a piece of practical advice
about seven weeks from now you will be
going completely insane it will be the
middle of midterm exams and you will
have discovered if you haven't already
that all the other students are both
smarter and harder working than you are
now of course they think the same about
you but that doesn't help very much the
roommate you like best will be in the
midst of some terrible personal crisis
that requires your constant support the
roommate you like least we'll have
adopted some personal habit even more
annoying than what you've had to put up
with so far you will have just had your
worst game rehearsal meeting whatever it
is the partner of your dreams will have
turned you down the whole universe will
seem to be against you but it's not the
universe that is turned on you you're
just trapped in the Yale bubble so
here's one way to get out go down to
trumbull street over there block a block
down the road turn right cross Whitney
Avenue by which action you leave Yale
behind walk another block or two to
where the access to the highway is and
turn
left on Orange Street and then just keep
on walking after a mile or two you'll
get to a place called East Rock Park
it's quite a large Park there's a lake a
hill paths all around and as you wander
around it will occur to you this is
October in New England one of the most
spectacularly beautiful natural scenes
on our entire planet you will be
reminded that there are people who are
not between the ages of 18 and 22 there
are mothers with babies middle-aged
joggers old married couples some
twelve-year-old kid practicing free
throws and you'll recall that the
universe also contains non-human animals
pet pet dogs are over-represented in
east rock but there are also dear swans
fish frogs turtles songbirds of all
types walk around for an hour or so and
then head back your problems will not be
gone in fact by losing an hour of study
time they might have gotten a little bit
worse but you may find that you have a
better perspective on their importance
east rock is of course not the only way
to escape the Yale bubble if you want to
see particularly far into the rest of
the universe i recommend the lightener
observatories tuesday night open houses
up on science hill or you could go to
New York or you could call your
grandmother or you could read something
that is not assigned for a class or go
out into the community and campaign for
your favorite political party or social
cause or just shut the door close your
eyes and let your mind run free there
are more and better ways to relieve
stress then yet another late night party
with other yay Lee's who are worried
about the exact same things that you are
focusing on the inside of the bubble
ratchets up the intensity and anxiety
it's not a stress reducer at all but the
bubble walls that separate Yale from the
rest of the universe are not the only
boundaries you will encounter there are
bubbles within the Yale bubble just as
the universe has what the cosmologists
call hierarchical structure out there in
the universe galaxies form into galaxies
clusters clusters formed super clusters
clusters and the superclusters form the
edges of the bubbles and there's recent
evidence that the bubbles themselves are
grouped together and once again the
university is similar to the universe
Yale is not one undifferentiated
experience there's a wide range of sub
structure academic departments sports
teams cultural organizations performing
arts groups secret and not so secret
societies residential colleges all sorts
of smaller bubbles inside the Yale
bubble any given student inhabits just a
few of these bubbles it's why everyone's
experience of Yale is different my own
experience of Yale involved a rather
bizarre mixture of singing groups and
astrophysics courses these two bubbles
were pretty separate from one another
although they did touch on a couple of
occasions in my sophomore year I was the
pitch pipe of the Dukes men thank you
those were the days those were the days
when I was an important person around
here and we were invited to sing at the
physics department christmas party we
needed the money so i took the gig but i
have to say i found it hard to perform
our usual antics in front of people who
were going to grade my exams the very
next day people in events look different
when viewed through different bubbles
the iridescent refraction that occurs
when the edges of the bubbles collide
provides an interesting point of view
this effect occurs strongly when faculty
and students interacting unusual places
in the supermarket or the bank or
something like that I vividly remember
my first year back as a faculty member
I'd been away from Yale for a few years
and coming back I found my habits
reverting to those of my 20 year old
self I was crossing the campus late one
night perhaps eleven o'clock at p.m. and
I got thirsty and wanted a soda so just
as I would have done a decade earlier I
went into the library we called it CCL
back then but now it's been renovated
into the vast library and there used to
be a bunch of vending machines down
there that we called machine city so I
trotted down to machine city and bought
myself a coke
on the way I passed a group of students
studying and they looked at me with
absolute horror and I kind of turned
around to see what demon was following
me and then I realized these students
were in my class and I was giving a
midterm exam the very next day and they
thought I was checking up on so I
scurried away because so that they could
get on with it pretending that I hadn't
noticed them there another one of those
awkward moments when bubbles collide and
I realized that my students were now
treating me just as I had treated the
physics faculty during the Dukes mins
performance not as fellow human beings
but as some kind of alternative life
form it really shouldn't be so awkward
one of the things that makes Yale great
is the personal interaction that's
possible here between faculty and
students but it takes them real out of
the bubble behavior on both sides to
realize that promise it took me a while
to get the hang of it both as a student
and later as a faculty member but when
that connection gets made it can be
really quite wonderful so let me
encourage you if you see a faculty
member in an unexpected situation don't
freak out we're probably not checking up
on your study habits we just want a soda
just like you and a friendly gesture
might be appreciated I did know one
other person who inhabited both the
astrophysics and the singing group
bubble a young woman so spectacularly
beautiful that I couldn't speak
coherently in her presence until our
25th reunion I then found out that she's
really a very nice person and that if I
hadn't been so terrified we might have
been friends after all we did have a lot
of common interests it was a real missed
opportunity I missed many opportunities
as a student and so will you as I said
before no one can possibly do all the
things that are to be done around here
but let me describe two other mistakes I
made in the hope that it might help you
avoid a particular kind of blunder then
as now Yale had some truly spectacular
classes that no one should miss these
are generally referred to by the name of
the grand
who teach them in my day we had Spence
which was a famous course on Chinese
history and scully and even more famous
course on art history both professor
Spence and professor Scully are now
retired but I don't doubt that you
already know their contemporary
equivalents I had a strangely negative
attitude toward these courses based now
I now think on a kind of adolescent
arrogance I refuse to take any of them
on the grounds that 600 Yale students
couldn't all be right the consequence of
this though is that I now know much less
than I might about Chinese history in
the history of art both of which would
in fact provide very useful background
for some of my current activities a
second missed opportunity occurred in
graduate school not here at Yale and
relates back to those cosmic bubbles I
mentioned at the beginning the discovery
of cosmic bubbles proved to be a major
advance in astrophysics detailed studies
of hierarchical structure provides some
of the best constraints on the origin
and evolution of the universe that we
have I could have made that discovery
but I didn't one of the options I had
when choosing my PhD thesis topic was to
work on galaxy maps just the thing that
led to the discovery of cosmic structure
but this seemed to me an amazingly
boring project the plan was to observe
twenty thousand galaxies and plot them
on a map take a spectrum find the
redshift calculate the distance put it
on the map lather rinse repeat twenty
thousand times what a bore so I did
something else instead but one of my
classmates clearer thinking and more
patient than I took on the project wrote
a clever piece of software to do all the
work and the paper she wrote has been
cited more often than my top four papers
combined looking back I think these
anecdotes reveal the same flaw in both
cases I was convinced that I knew what I
was doing so much so that I refuse to
try anything outside of what had become
my comfort zone my bubble but that
bubble was really quite small and so I
missed out fortunately I got over my
silly and
Timothy toward big popular courses by my
senior year and almost accidentally took
the intro to film studies course this is
about as far from my comfort zone as
possible a big lecture course on visual
art and here I have to apologize to d
miller a distinguished art historian and
confess that this is an area in which I
have neither talent nor great interest
nevertheless taking that course was
perhaps the single best thing I did at
Yale knowing little about visual images
I had imagined that the point of going
to the movies was to find out how the
plot turned out that the content of the
film was more or less contained within
the words of the script but it turned
out greatly to my surprise that whole
realms of meaning are contained within
the images themselves who knew I did but
after taking that course I began to have
an inkling of an area of human
experience that I otherwise would have
completely missed out and this has
enriched every single one of the
embarrassingly large numbers of hours
that I've since spent watching TV so in
retrospect that course enhanced my life
more than any other academic experience
I've ever had similarly the missed
opportunity to work on galaxy maps
indicated a narrow view of what
interesting academic work might consist
of this is a flaw I'm currently trying
to push back against I've become
involved in Yale's collaboration with
the National University of Singapore to
create a new liberal arts college on the
other side of the world trying to bridge
the cultural political and intellectual
gaps between New Haven and Singapore is
an entirely new kind of challenge for me
it's a really interesting and exciting
project it's also been intensely
controversial some people think that the
nature of sync of the Singapore bubble
is such that we shouldn't be attempting
to work with them at all it's just the
kind of debate that one hopes for it a
place like Yale and that we hope will
occur in the new college in Singapore as
well one of the things that recently
happened in this project is we've hired
the first batch of faculty for this
endeavor they're fascinating group many
will be on campus here during the coming
year
and I hope that a few of them of you
will get to know them the people
attracted to this kind of thing tend to
be what the demographers call
multi-state migrants people who grew up
in one place and culture and shifted
repeatedly to other places and cultures
in other words bubble Buster's I too am
an interstate migrant but in my case the
states involved are Massachusetts in
Connecticut and somehow going from Yale
to Harvard and back doesn't really seem
all that imaginative so I'm very
grateful that in middle age I will
finally be able to do something that you
all can do in the next few years namely
study abroad it's a particularly fine
way to escape from the Yale bubble and
its various sub bubbles you know I don't
remember much from freshman week as such
in part due to activities better left
undiscussed in the presence of Dean's
but one incident has stuck with me I
remember going to a meal with two new
friends the kinds of friends that you
know you met 15 years been 15 minutes
ago and have become close buddies some
of whom I should tell you one doesn't
see again until the day before
commencement one of us noticed someone
sitting alone in the dining hall and
insisted that as a friendly gesture we
should join him to our embarrassment he
turned out not to be a freshman but an
upperclassman a junior I think quite
jaded about Yale and about life he
smiled wistfully at our youthful
enthusiasm and just shook his head AHA
youth he said looking back at us from
the advanced age of 20 and so my final
piece of advice today is this don't be
that guy hold fiercely to the sense of
excitement and adventure and anxiety
that you now have at Yale and for the
rest of your life keep having meals with
people you've never met keep taking
courses on things you know nothing about
keep trying activities you've never done
before and when you graduate don't
imagine for one minute that the course
of your life is somehow set in
don't mistake the interior of one
particular bubble for the whole of our
wide-ranging very and fascinating
University much less for the universe
itself and with that let me thank you
for your attention and welcome to Yale
Thank You professor Baylin for your
thoughtful and wise words and now as
part of this gathering we'd like to
introduce you to a long-standing Yale
tradition the singing of our alma mater
bright college years you will sing it
many times in your lives as students and
then as alumni so it is fitting that you
begin your Yale career by singing it
together for the very first time as a
class the words in tune may be
unfamiliar right now but you soon will
learn them by heart some representatives
of the Yale glee club are here today to
lead us they will sing the first verse
and then I ask that you rise and sing
both vs you've been given a Yale
handkerchief and is it is our custom to
waive it from your right to left okay on
the last line now let me now call on
Yale glee club president and morris
college resident of the class of 2013
mr. Eli Mitchell Larson and the Yale
glee club who will be accompanied on the
organ by mr. Simon Jacobs